Today I want to talk to you about something that
might seem strange, almost a
contradiction.
All our lives we've been told,
"Walk, [music] walk as much as you can, it's
good for you,"
and no one doubts it.
The daily walk is a
sacred ritual, a moment for us, for our
heart, for our mind.
How many times after lunch have you [music]
taken your hat and gone out for a
walk along the street or in the park
near your house, feeling that you were doing
the right thing and that you were right.
But if I told you he's in his
70s or even 80s,
insisting only on walking and logging
mile after mile might not
be the best strategy—
in fact, it might even mask
problems you're not addressing.   I
'm not suggesting you hang up your sneakers
, by any means,
but today I want to explore a
new territory together, a territory where
quality of movement trumps quantity,
where you'll discover two things, just two, that
the latest science indicates are
powerful allies for aging not
only well, but with strength, balance,
and a vitality you perhaps thought you'd
lost.  Get ready because we're about to
challenge one of the
most deeply held beliefs about wellness
after 70, and I assure you, by the
end of this video you'll look at your
body with completely different eyes.
Let's start with a fact.  Walking is a
great cardiovascular activity.   There's
no arguing about this, but once we reach
a certain age, our bodies change
their priorities, and we should do the
same.  Think about your joints,
your knees, your hips.  They
worked for you for 70-80 years.  Every
step you've taken in your life has
asked something of those cartilages,
those [music] tendons.
Continuing to subject them to
repetitive stress for hours, every day, without
giving them anything else, can lead to
wear and tear that the body can no longer
compensate for, as it did at 40.
It's a bit like continuing to use a
vintage Fiat 500 for long
motorway trips.  It's a wonderful machine,
but it needs
different, more targeted, more intelligent maintenance.
And here comes the first point that might
make you say, "I hadn't thought of that."
Walking alone does very little to
counteract one of the greatest
silent enemies of aging,
sarcopenia.
It's a bit of a technical word, I know, but it
simply refers to the natural loss
of muscle mass and strength that occurs
as we age.
Consider that after the age of 60, the rate of
this loss accelerates dramatically,
reaching up to 1% of muscle mass
lost every single year.
According to the Cleveland Clinic, between the ages of 65 and
80, you can lose up to 8%
of your muscle mass per decade.
And this doesn't just mean feeling a
little weaker when you climb hills, it
means having a slower metabolism
, a higher risk of diabetes,
more fragile bones, and above all, a
reduced ability to react to
unexpected events, like a step you didn't
see or an uneven sidewalk.
Walking doesn't build new
muscle mass, it keeps your heart fit,
yes, but it doesn't build.  And this is where
our first
revolutionary thing comes in.  The first thing
you should do is engage in
strength training.  I know what you're
thinking,
but at my age I have to
lift weights like a kid in the
gym.
The image is wrong, but the concept is very
correct.
And here I have to be honest with you.  I
firmly believe that the biggest mistake
in communicating about the health of the
elderly has been to talk only
about walking, completely neglecting
muscle training.
It was a huge cultural mistake and the
data proves it.
Strength training for a
seventy-year-old isn't a muscle competition, it
's not sweat and effort, it's a dialogue with
your body to keep it
responsive, robust, and functional.
Recent studies such as those published
by the Mayo Clinic have shown that
targeted resistance training can
not only slow, but in some cases
even reverse, aging-
related changes in muscle fibers
.   Did
you understand correctly?  Reversing is not
science fiction, it's biology.
And it's not about lifting
heavy loads, sometimes it's not even about
lifting weights.
Have you ever heard of
isometric exercises?
They are muscle contractions that occur
without joint movement.
Imagine pushing with all your
strength against a wall.  The wall isn't
moving, but your muscles are
working hard.
A practical and very simple example, the
wall sit, the chair against the wall.  Lean your
back against a wall, bend your knees as
if you were sitting on an invisible chair,
and hold the position for 20-30
seconds.
Do you feel your thigh muscles
burning?
That's pure strength, built to be completely
safe for your joints,
with no impact whatsoever.
And now comes the second one. I hadn't
thought of that.  The British Journal of Sports
Medicine published a study
demonstrating that isometric exercises,
particularly the wall seat and plank,
are among the most effective methods
overall for lowering
blood pressure.
more effective than running, more effective
than fast walking.
Who would have ever thought that
standing still against a wall could do
more good for blood pressure than an
hour-long walk?  You can use
simple elastic bands, the ones that
cost a few euros in any
sports shop.
You can do push-ups
against the kitchen wall or
lift half-liter bottles of water
while sitting in an
armchair watching the news.
The goal is not extreme fatigue, but
constant stimulation.
Two or three sessions a week, even
just 15-20 minutes, can make a
difference that walking alone
never can.  Think about the feeling
of carrying shopping bags from the
market effortlessly.  to get up from a
chair without having to put your hands on the
armrests, to lift [music] a
grandchild and make him laugh without feeling your
back protest.  This is the real
reward, not a number on a
scale, but freedom in
everyday gestures.
And speaking of everyday gestures, I'd
like to know something.  What's
that little everyday chore
you wish could go back to being a
simple gesture?  Open a jar, climb the
stairs without getting out of breath?  Write it to me in a
comment.  Let's discuss these
small, big goals.
And now let's move on to the second thing,
something even deeper that has to do
with the mind as much as
the body.  Something that in my opinion is the
true watershed between aging
suffered and aging lived to the
full.
Have you ever wondered how you know,
even with your eyes closed, whether your arm
is straight or bent?
Or how do you manage to walk on a
slightly uneven sidewalk without
constantly looking at your feet?
This is thanks to proprioception.
It's a kind of sixth sense that allows
your brain to know exactly
where every part of your body is located
in space at any given moment.
It's what allows you to bring a
cup of coffee to your [music] mouth
without spilling it, to go down a
step without thinking, to turn around
when someone calls you without losing
your balance.
With age this sense fades.
slowly, silently
and as it fades
the risk of falls increases exponentially.
The Italian data from the Istituto Superiore
di Sanità are impressive and I believe they are
not discussed enough.  Nearly
29% of people over 65 in Italy fall at least
once a year.
Among those over eighty-five, the figure
rises to 31%.
Every year in our country
approximately 120,000 fractures [music] of the
femur are recorded among the elderly and 40% of the
elderly live with the constant fear
[music] of falling.
This fear is sometimes almost worse
than the fall itself because it leads to
less movement, to giving up going
out, to shutting oneself in at home, to a loss of
independence and social relationships.  It's
a terrible vicious cycle.
Walking on smooth,
familiar terrain, like the usual path in the
park or along the avenue, does very little
to train this sixth sense; in fact, it makes it
lazy because the brain goes into
automatic mode, no longer having to calculate,
[music] adapt, react.
This is why the second thing to do is to
dedicate yourself to activities that awaken your
own,
and the undisputed king of these disciplines,
the one that science has studied most
thoroughly, is taic.
Don't see it as some strange
oriental martial art, but as poetry
in motion.
Slow, fluid, controlled movements that
force your brain to
re-establish a deep connection with
every muscle, every tendon, every
inch of your body.  A
Stanford University study showed
that consistent stretching reduces the
risk of falls by up to 58% compared
to simple stretching.  and another
study showed a reduction in
recurrent falls of up to 70%.
70%
is a huge number that no medicine,
no supplement, no pair of
orthopedic shoes can promise.
But you don't have to sign up for a
tai chi class.  You can start with very
simple exercises at home.  Try
balancing on one leg while
holding lightly on a table or
chair for 10 seconds.  Then switch
legs.  When you feel confident, try
doing it without support.  Try walking
slowly down the corridor, placing one
foot directly in front of the other,
heel to toe, like a tightrope walker
on an imaginary line.  Or, and
this is a tip I love, try
brushing your teeth while standing on one leg
.  It seems silly, but you're
training your brain to maintain
balance while engaged in
another activity.  it is truly
pure exception.  And here's the third one, I hadn't
thought of that.  Training your
posture doesn't just improve
your physical balance.  A study
published in Plus One has shown that
controlled breathing and
conscious bodywork like Tai Chi improve
concentration, reduce anxiety and,
above all, restore a
priceless confidence in your body.  It's the
feeling of being in control of your
movements, not a fearful passenger.  It's
the difference between leaving your house
afraid you'll trip and leaving your house
knowing that your body knows how to
react.  So what did we discover
today?  that after 70 the secret
is not to walk more, but to move better.
Integrate your beloved walk, which
remains a precious moment for the heart and
soul, with these two very
powerful practices.
Smart strength training to
keep your muscles toned, responsive, and
capable of protecting you.  It's a work
on balance and your own exception
to feel stable and safe like an
oak tree.   You
don't have to turn your life upside down.   You
don't have to join a gym, you don't have to
buy expensive equipment.
It's about adding, not
replacing.
Add 15 minutes of
strength training two or three times a week.
Add 10 minutes of
balance exercises every morning, perhaps before
heading out for your walk.
Small seeds that day after day
will grow a robust and luxuriant tree of well-being
.
Think of the inhabitants of the blue zones of
our Sardinia, those
inland towns where some of the
longest-lived centenarians in the world live.   They
don't spend their days running marathons
or counting steps on a
digital watch.   They
move constantly, in a
natural and varied way.  They lift weights
while working the land, they bend over, they go up
and down hilly paths,
they keep their body active in all
its aspects and genetics, as
studies have shown, have an impact of less
than 10%.  The rest is lifestyle,
smart exercise,
healthy eating, and—let's never forget—
strong social relationships.
Here, maybe this is the fourth "I
hadn't thought of that."  Sardinian centenarians don't
do structured physical exercise,
yet their bodies remain strong and
balanced because every gesture of their
day is, in effect, a
complete workout.  My hope with this
video is not to give you a magic recipe,
but to offer you a new perspective,
an invitation to look at your body, not
with resignation, but with curiosity and
intelligence,
to become the architect of your own
well-being, building a future where
every step, even the shortest, is
stronger, more confident, and more vibrant.
If you found what I've
shared today helpful, please share this video
with someone you love, someone
who might need it.  And don't
forget to tell me about your
experience in the comments.
Have you tried any of these
exercises yet?
How did you feel?  I would really
love to read your story.  See you soon.